madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition l'hommage vibrant à kurosawa
celui qui fut l'un des maîtres du cinéma
mondial c'était à aujourd'hui on lui
doit de nombreux chefs-d'oeuvre comme
les sept samouraïs ou kagemusha au
canada les deux boîtes noires de
l'appareil de la suisse air sont
localisées pourraient être remontées
aujourd'hui les conversations entre
pilotes et tour de contrôle ont été
rendus publics
la rentrée de françois bayrou à
l'université d'été des jeunes démocrates
celui qui pourrait bien prendre la tête
de l'udf demande clarté et apaisement
la cinquième édition de la mostra avec
en compétition voleurs de vie interprété
par sandrine bonnaire et emmanuelle
béart
deux actrices deux complices sur les
canaux à venise je vous propose d'ouvrir
ce journal avec l'adieu à kurzawa à
nommage unanime allant presque jusqu'à
la vénération pour celui qui fut l'un
des grands metteurs en scène du siècle
que rosa oie s'est donc éteint ce matin
à l'âge de 88 ans il avait signé
plusieurs chefs-d'oeuvre dont les sept
samouraïs kagemusha palme d'or à cannes
ou encore anne saluée dans le monde
entier le réalisateur japonais
paradoxalement n'avaient pas trouvé la
même reconnaissance dans son propre pays
portraits hommages michel mompontet
oh parce qu'il savait que tout homme est
un génie quand ils rêvent kurosawa aura
jusqu'au bout tenter de reconstituer ses
rêves les plus beaux ceux du monde de sa
propre enfance et de son grand livre
d'image dans un japon qu'il voyait
éternelle il animait des fantômes dont
lui seul semblait encore connaître les
codes les rites et les secrets disparu
30 chef-d'oeuvre 55 ans de cinéma est
pour lui cet instant fugace de bonheur
cet instant où il savait que c'était
exactement comment ses rêves et qu'à
nouveau il allait réussir à emmener des
millions de spectateurs et bailly dans
son imaginaire souza là les sept
samouraïs kagemusha ran autant de
chefs-d'oeuvre qui lui avait fait gravir
dès 1951 les plus hautes marches des
festivals de la planète cinéma il était
vénéré par tous comme un empereur
intimidant et adulé kurzawa était le
shakespeare visuel du cinéma moderne
pourtant cet humaniste ombrageux
n'aimait rien tant qu'à la peinture sa
palette à cinématographique en était
imprégné
en 1990 n'avait-il pas organiser pour
son film rêve
la rencontre du jeune kurosawa et de ses
ambitions de peintres naissant avec un
certain vincent van gogh
un gigantesque jeu électronique comme
une course dans le temps pour venir
saluer le génial hollandais
mais kurosawa nourrissent et son cinéma
aussi de littérature dostoïevski
shakespeare avons tous auteurs dont il
partageait la fureur et la démesure
plusieurs fois il adapta magistralement
et l'un et l'autre presque fidèlement
mais dans sa langue et avec ses propres
visions
ozawa s'est trompé au moins sur un point
quand il prétendait que rien ne subsiste
et de ce japon la de ce japon de ses
rêves que tout était englouti partis en
fumée tout sauf quand même 30
chef-d'oeuvre sauf 60 heures de cinéma
rêvé par un géant
au canada les deux boîtes noires du vol
de lassus serre ont été localisées
pourraient être remontées aujourd'hui à
la surface si la météo le permet nous y
reviendrons mais d'abord le pèlerinage
des familles des victimes sur les lieux
de la catastrophe
le séant comme dernier lien dominique
d'erding sur les rochers du bord de mer
les infirmières de la croix-rouge
choisissent avec soin les cailloux
qu'elle ramasse ses petit morceau de
granit ce sont des morceaux de peggy's
cove que nous réclament les familles les
proches
ils nous demandent de leur en faire
cadeau en souvenir de cet endroit et
espère sans doute être aussi solide que
ces rochers aujourd'hui encore par lou
viennent les produits chimiques en
silence se recueillir devant l'océan
déposer quelques pleurs au pied d'un
phare devenu memoria nidia a perdu sa
soeur dans l'accident si colony
je ne voulais pas venir
il se fait du bien
ça m'a fait au moins je sais où aller
ils se contentent pour ça qu'elle est un
endroit magnifique comme la suisse
essaie de venir en suisse
elle est là bas comment avez-vous appris
sa disparition
c'était terrible tu me suis réveillé
exactement au moment du crash
s'il était très proche d'elle
et j'ai pas pu dormir et j'ai mis la
radio à 5h30
parce qu'un europe c'était casse en
théorie qui sont donnés la nouvelle et
j'étais seul et je suis persuadé que
c'était fini j'ai jamais eu de l'espoir
et qu'elle j'ai entendu à 6 heures du
matin je pensais que c'était une bombe
et je voudrais savoir qu'est ce que tu
arrivé
bien sûr ça nous ramènera pas les corps
mais au moins on pourra prévoir
dans la petite église anglicane de saint
john c'est bientôt l'heure de l'office
sur le registre les quelques mots d'une
autre famille suisse c'est leur fille
qu'ils ont perdu le pasteur s'apprête à
célébrer une messe de circonstance la
paroisse d'une soixantaine dame a elle
aussi été traumatisée par le drame
t'es sûr que tous sont très touchés vous
n'avez qu'à regarder autour de vous
rares sont ceux qui sortent de chez eux
en se rendant en pèlerinage à peggy's
cove ses visiteurs aux yeux rougis de
larmes n'auront rien appris des causes
de l'accident l'enquète ne fait que
commencer promet d'être longue
mais le temps d'un adieu ils se seront
sentis plus proche de ceux qui l'ont
perdue et c'est déjà beaucoup
précisément du côté de l'anc est
maintenant je vous disais les boîtes
noires seront remontés dans les heures
qui viennent pour l'instant aucune
certitude quant aux causes de l'accident
mais les conversations rendu public
aujourd'hui entre pilotes et tour de
contrôle avant la catastrophe pourront
aider les enquêteurs romuald venant
depuis plus d'une heure trente le vol
swissair 111 a quitté new york direction
genève à 22h14 l'avion qui volent à
11000 mètres son altitude de croisière
envoie son premier message de détresse
le pilote exécute calmement la procédure
panne panne panne fumer à bord demandons
déviation immédiate vers boston je
suppose c'est la tour de contrôle de
moncton sur la côte sud est du canada
qui répondent ne préférez vous pas
halifax
à cet instant-là paris se trouve à 110
km d'halifax au sud du canada alors que
boston est distant de près de 500 km
dans l'appareil
la fumée commence à envahir le copte
alors les deux pilotes quand ils leur
masque à oxygène
affirmatif préférons halifax orienté
nous suit sur 111 est plein commence
alors pour l'équipage un contre la
montre car l'avion est trop et surtout
beaucoup trop lourd
230 tonnes au décollage pour traverser
l'atlantique soit 30 tonnes de trop pour
atterrir la tour de contrôle
demande un changement de cap
virée sur la gauche pour perdre de
l'altitude vous avez 48 kilomètres avant
la piste
48km pas assez de temps pour larguer les
30 tonnes de carburant il est 22 heures
17 altitude de 8000 mètres la tour
autorise le vol 111 à virer plus
largement sur sa gauche pour revenir sur
l'atlantique et se débarrasser du
kérosène viré et dites-nous quand vous
êtes prêts à larguer 22h23 l'avion vers
1000 mètres par minute il se trouve
désormais à 2500 mètres d'altitude
le commandant de bord loos alors un
second message dallaire ne le déclarent
en situation d'urgence
il nous faut acquérir immédiatement ce
seront les derniers mots venus du
cockpit et au lieu de vivre une deuxième
fois à gauche pour revenir vers halifax
les radars des ronds l'avion quitté
violemment sa trajectoire sur la droite
en réalisant une vous que le couple et
puis plus rien
un virage à droite qui n'a pas été
expliqué lors de la conférence de presse
du conseil canadien des transports
mais les deux boîtes noires ont diront
peut-être plus sur ce changement de cap
brutal et sur les raisons de l'incendié
à bord claude allègre était toute à
l'heure l'invité du club de la presse
d'europe 1 le ministre de l'éducation
est revenu sur l'état de santé de jean
pierre chevènement déclarant qu'il était
dans un état stationnaire et alarmant le
terme alarmant a ajouté que d'alex
justifie par la crainte de séquelles
très difficile
fin de citation et ses deux mains qu'à
nouveau communiqué du val-de-grâce
devrait donner quelques précisions sur
l'état de santé de jean pierre
chevènement en cette période de rentrée
scolaire après les classes primaires et
les collèges c'est au tour des lycéens
de reprendre le chemin de l'école
aux côtés de ces élèves désormais des
aides éducateurs qui ont su en une année
démontrer la nécessité de leur présence
ils étaient quarante mille l'an passé
que d'allègre promet une nouvelle vague
de vingt mille emplois jeunes dans les
établissements cette année reportage au
collège molière d'ivry stéphane haumant
et claude barnier donc vous venez avec
votre il parle déjà avec l'assurance
d'un professeur et c'est sa seconde
rentrée
mais rodolphe gardait de 24 ans occupe
ici un emploi jeune et d'éducateurs dans
un collège rien à voir avec un
surveillant
il est chargé du soutien aux élèves
qu'on est réellement là pour les aider
dans leur travail
pour ce qui est bien sûr le cas des
professeurs mais en général c'est pas
vraiment le cas les surveillants donc on
a vraiment un contact différent avec
retorde gardette secondes les
professeurs
l'an dernier il a supervisé tous les
travaux sur ordinateur de la classe de
physique pour une expo sur l'eau son
jeune âge facilite le contact les
relations qui pouvait avoir avec les
élèves n'étaient pas les mêmes il allait
plus facilement vers rodolphe pour le
graphisme pour la présentation du
panneau les relations étaient plus
faciles avec moi il y avait certaines
rigidités de l'éducation nationale a
déjà recruté 40 mille aides éducateurs
en emplois jeunes il y en aura 20 mille
de plus cette année un contrat de cinq
ans une aubaine pour isabelle shop
après deux ans de chômage lé niveau bac
+5 en psychologie
ici elle gagne 5200 francs le smic un
peu décourageant ray mais bon étant
donné que
j'ai pas de travail dans le milieu
médical
je peux pas espérer plus non plus donc
c'est ça ou c'est rien du tout quoi le
ministère voudrait généraliser
l'opération dans les cinquante cinq
mille établissements publics du pays
mais les aides éducateurs sont souvent
considérés comme des intrus à l'école on
n'a pas l'habitude dans l'éducation
nationale c'est un milieu qui est quand
même assez assez fermé on est un peu une
forteresse donc à voir ces gens qui ont
un regard qu'il ceux qui se sont pas
préparés à être dans ce milieu on a tout
à inventer avec isabelle et rodolphe eux
se sont inventé un nouvel avenir
désormais il espère bien faire carrière
dans le milieu éducatif
le ministre de l'éducation présentait il
ya quelques jours son projet pour
l'école de l'an 2000 avec comme principe
de base un enseignement adapté au rythme
scolaire de l'enfant
et bien c'est déjà sur ce concept que
les enseignants chine par exemple
établissent leur programme
l'exemple de cette fillette de dix ans
qu'isabelle baissière et tristan le braz
ont suivi pour sa dernière année de
primaire
quand sa maman s'occupe de sa coiffure
cimetière où est élevé depuis trois
quarts d'heure elle est déjà descendu
avec son père pour faire 20 minutes de
jogging dans la cité est un petit
plastique et s'apprête à attaquer sa
journée d'école
à 9 ans elle est levée à 6 heures du
matin et récapitule les livres
nécessaires à sa journée à mon cahier
des dérogations christ mon cahier de
dicter son cahier de caractères chinois
et mon cahier répercussions les livres
n'ont pas l'air bien lourd mais le
cartable pèse quand même un peu plus de
sept kilos que l'écolière va transporter
un quart d'heure jusqu'à l'école elle
doit y arriver peu avant 7h30 les jours
ordinaires un peu plus tôt qu'on sa
classe est de corvée de balayage les
enfants des villes ont en général des
sacs à dos pour éviter de s'abîmer la
colonne vertébrale l'école primaire
numéro 5 de faim de taille ne fait pas
exception
juste un peu plus disciplinés peut-être
car les familles du quartier sont
presque toutes militaire le cours de
maths et le deuxième cours de la journée
il y a six co par jour cinq jours par
semaine en cm2 6 heures de chinois six
heures de maths de d'informatique et de
d'anglais le matin quand les pétillants
l'esprit frais l'éducation politique
c'est pour l'après midi comme les
activités d'éveil
en général les courts principaux sont
tous planifiée pour le matin alors que
l'après midi on a plutôt des cours de
musique
les travaux manuels des coûts vous les
enfants sont très animées et de bonne
humeur
les arts plastiques la peinture le sport
interviennent après le repas un moindre
mal si les enfants sont un peu fatigués
il faut dire qu'ils ont bien peu de
vacances par rapport à notre île est
français soigneusement entrecoupé un
mois en hiver pour le nouvel an chinois
est cette semaine en été s'ils ont
quelques rares jours fériés la semaine
financières qui commence demain
s'annonce très mouvementée après la
russie ce sens les marchés émergents qui
sont la cible des spéculateurs faisant
ressurgir le spectre de la crise
mondiale les explications de jean paul
chapelle malgré les sourires de façade
c'est une réunion de crise qui s'est
tenue vendredi au fonds monétaire
international
venezuela chili argentine en tout neuf
pays d'amérique du sud ont diligenté
leurs ministres des finances
ces pays émergents sont la nouvelle
cible des spéculateurs
dans l'après midi la bourse de sao paulo
perd des 10% mouvement de panique sur
les marchés brésiliens le risque de
crise mondiale est montée d'un cran
nous aurons un choc en europe qui ne
sera pas tellement un choc de
spéculation qui sera d'abord un choc
bancaire parce que les banques
européennes vont perdre beaucoup
d'argent si l'amérique latine craque et
qui sera un choc de commerce
international la demande monte à la
demande de ces pays va diminuer
brutalement et ça affectera fortement
les perspectives de croissance en europe
l'amérique latine n'a pas encore craqué
le scénario catastrophe n'est pas
forcément le plus probable pour
l'instant l'europe est assez
indépendante pour se protéger de la
contagion à new york wall street a vécu
une des pires semaines de son histoire
ou 1 5% en cinq jours très nerveuse
la bourse de paris a connu aussi des
montagnes russes mais elles résistent
mieux -0 5% comme l'europe est un pôle
de stabilité
l'argent arrive en europe et cela fait
baisser les taux d'intérêt et si les
taux d'intérêt baissent
l'investissement est stimulée et ça
c'est bon pour la croissance
donc il ya des effets dans les deux sens
il faudra revoir le moment venu les
conséquences qu'on en tire les
conséquences le ministre de l'économie
devrait les dévoiler bientôt et revoir à
la baisse la croissance prévue en france
l'an prochain
les 2,8 pour cent tomberont sans doute à
2,7 pour cent moins de croissance s'est
un peu moins de richesse est un peu
moins d'emplois en russie le pays sans
gouvernement depuis quinze jours tentera
de maths de se trouver un premier
ministre en effet la douma doit se
prononcer pour la deuxième fois sur le
candidat présenté par boris eltsine et
puis tout à l'heure le général hillier
bed a prédit des émeutes dans une
semaine si la situation n'évolue pas
gilles rabin et franck brisset en temps
de crise ce sont eux qui dirigent la
russie les gouverneurs de régions
anonymes pour la plupart ils sont
effrayés par le choc de la crise
économique dans leur province et ils ne
le cachent plus avec tchernomirdine
l'explication vient d'être rude
ils sont en première ligne ils savent
que le peuple est à bout de patience
il est le gouvernement
créer un tribunal pour les juger comme
on a fait avec les criminels nazis
la colère de tchernomirdine dure depuis
trois jours il croyait être le nouveau
maître du jeu et tout lui échappe depuis
qu'il est revenu au pouvoir il n'a
encore rien fait pour tenter de ralentir
le plongeon du rouet regarder trois fois
on a dû changer les prix trois fois
aujourd'hui les mêmes vieillard sous les
même bannière depuis dix ans mais cette
année il danse parce qu'il voit venir
une deuxième révolution d'octobre en
septembre aucun premier ministre ne
pourra être investi par la douma sans
eux sans les communistes je veux revenir
au communisme j'en ai ras-le-bol
capitalisme oui mais l'élite soviétique
d'hier a disparu les communistes
d'aujourd'hui leurs propres camarades du
temps des soviets les considérer comme
trop médiocre pour exercer de hautes
fonctions
on a vécu tant de crise
depuis 91 que j'ai presque moins peur je
suis triste je suis inquiète mais je ne
sais pas ce que moins peur en 91 compte
sur les charges
j'aime plus peur de russes sur trois
craignent aujourd'hui un putsch
militaire parce que les officiers ne
sont plus payés depuis longtemps parce
que l'armée a été vaincu en tchétchénie
et humilié la russie désemparés se
cherche un sauveur et le sol possible à
une casquette de generali et bed qui a
pris ses marques en se disant prêt si le
peuple la peine
yab aide loujkov le maire de la capitale
qui offrait ce dimanche une fête peut
être l'une des derniers billets v12
coffe le plus dangereux des deux n'est
peut-être pas celui auquel on pense
mais la russie n'a plus le choix
qu'entre deux et le communisme après la
disparition d'une dizaine de diplomates
iraniens en afghanistan l'iran menace
les talibans d'intervention militaire un
droit de légitime défense selon téhéran
qui pour autant ne ferme pas la voie à
une solution diplomatique l'iran qui a
rejeté aujourd'hui la mise en garde les
etats-unis contre toute ingérence en
afghanistan politique française à
présent françois bayrou soigne sa
rentrée politique que celui qui pourrait
prendre la tête de l'udf d'ici peu a
clôturé l'université d'été des jeunes
démocrates est la grande motte par un
discours ferme appelant à la clarté et à
l'apaisement car le comment et yann
streiff l'udf est mal en point
fragilisé par le départ d'alain madelin
et de ses amis affaibli par ses
querelles internes
elle doit aujourd'hui se trouver un
avenir c'est le nouveau pari de françois
bayrou qui devrait succéder à françois
léotard à la tête du parti dans une
dizaine de jours
françois bayrou dont le projet pour
construire une nouvelle udf s'articule
autour d'un mot clé la clarté vis-à-vis
du front national mais aussi à l'égard
du parti d'alain madelin dont la
position sur le sujet reste encore pour
le moins
ambigu comme chacun le sait je n'ai pas
approuvé les choix qui ont été ceux de
démocratie libérale pour autant je ne
veux pas que nous ayons entre nous des
relations d'adversaires nous sommes
alliés
je n'approuve pas tout je discute mais
je propose que la règle soit la règle du
respect clarté enfin à l'égard de
l'europe
françois bayrou a longuement réaffirmer
son ambition aujourd'hui faire de l'udf
le grand mouvement européen de la vie
politique française pour mieux rebondir
à l'occasion de la prochaine échéance
électorale les élections européennes de
juin 99 avec l'éclatement de
l'opposition l'udf doit désormais
trouver un nouveau souffle pour tenter
de préserver l'espace politique qu'elle
occupait au sein de la droite et
conserver sa place de partenaire
privilégié vis-à-vis du rpr un pari qui
pour beaucoup prend aujourd'hui des
allures de quitte ou double alain
madelin était aujourd'hui l'invité de
l'émission de michèle cotta polémique le
président de démocratie libérale est
revenu sur la situation de jacques blanc
élu avec les voix du front national à la
présidence du languedoc-roussillon en
l'écoutant
aujourd'hui avec le temps on s'aperçoit
que jacques blanc fait pas d'alliance
avec le front national
il bénéficie il a bénéficié des voix du
front national je vais regretter parce
que je pense que c'est une erreur je
continue à dire ça mais ça ne mérite pas
le bannissement à vie de la politique
autour de moi ton de vous peut-être vous
avez des gens qui disent ville blanc
kahnawake le vise c'est horrible ce
qu'il a fait et puis
les deux sont des gens bien alors moi je
voudrais si elle fait c'est pas de faire
un mur à l'intérieur de l'opposition
s'est essayé de montrer et c'est ce
qu'on va essayer de faire je crois qu'on
y arrive a cédé aujourd'hui qu'on peut
réconcilier les a et les unes françois
hollande premier secrétaire national du
parti socialiste estime quant à lui que
démocratie libérale est une passerelle
entre le front national et la droite
la dernière des universités d'été avec à
ramatuelle celle des radicaux de gauche
emmenée par jean michel baylet bernard
tapie en son temps le revest offert un
vrai succès électoral aux européennes
aujourd'hui le parti recherche un
nouveau souffle et pour jouer sa
différence à inscrire le bonheur à son
programme
alban nicosie et bernard conner on dit
parfois qu'un cadre agréable aide à
trouver l'inspiration
les radicaux de gauche ont inscrit le
bonheur à leur programme une tournée
générale de bonheur voilà un thème qui
semble au moins bien qu'on sensuel c'est
aristote qui définissent et la politique
comme l'art de gouverner les peuples
pour leur bonheur à l'art ya beaucoup à
faire
de nombreux ateliers comme autant de
laboratoires d'idées les radicaux sont
conscients de leur poids très relatif
tout à côté du ps alors ils entendent
servir d'aiguillon et serait tout à fait
dommage qu'une sorte de rouleau
compresseur d'uniformité qui passent sur
les différentes familles de la gauche
c'est bien que chacun dans cette
formation polyphonique puisse donner un
petit peu de la loi les mélodies change
donc chez les radicaux les étoiles
filantes tapis kouchner sont repartis
désormais les vedettes ne confondent pas
les gens
la famille et j'ai parti radical
lui pas de faire de la politique et j'en
serai encore plus crédible comme ça
8 mai les chansons moi je fais des
discours mr en fait nous sommes pas de
versailles georges
le refrain c'est donc le droit au
bonheur pour tous pas sûr que ça fasse
un disque d'or mais un thème séduisant
qui pourrait convenir au grand frère le
ps histoire pour les radicaux de
profiter des vents favorables
bien à l'abri près du vaisseau
socialiste monseigneur blier a été
intronisé aujourd'hui archevêque de lyon
il succède à monseigneur balande décédé
en mars dernier tout juste une semaine
après avoir été nommé une nouvelle
explosion au gaz cette fois ci à garges
les gonesse dans le val d'oise une
cinquantaine de pavillons endommagé le
bruit de la déflagration a été d'une
rare violence
le bilan fait état d'un mort un
sexagénaire découvert dans les décombres
de son habitation
plusieurs blessés et de nombreux sans
abri quant à l'explosion qui s'est
produite hier dans un immeuble du cannet
cinq blessés sont toujours hospitalisés
à l'heure qu'il est la porte de
versailles jusqu'à deux mâles le salon
des modes de vie il s'adresse à tous les
amateurs de la mode branchée voici ce
qu'il faudra apporter pour être très
tendance l'été prochain ce film et elle
frédérick basile il ya ceux qui mettent
un point d'honneur à naviguer à contre
courant ceux qui suivent leur bonhomme
de chemin et les autres qui ferait
n'importe quoi pour être dans le vent
ici on s'adresse aux mordus la mode pour
qui tous les six mois
il faut faire table rase du passé
parce que nous sommes tous des nomades
urbains des citoyens et rang final vaut
une marque japonaise comme son nom ne
l'indiqué pas nous proposons 44 poche et
un poids plume 300 grammes à peine un
manteau à garnir une maison ambulante
il a à la fois à côté fonctionnel
un côté pratique puisqu'il est conçu
comme un vêtement qu'on puisse emmener
partout et qu'il soit donc très facile à
utiliser pour se chauffer dans une
petite poche et qui permettent de tout
emmener avec soi vêtements protecteurs
plus rien ne dépasse
celui ci fait office digue lui il est
signé air new gold et avec lui on peut
assister à un concert de johnny même
sous des trombes d'eau le voleur et ses
dizaines de milliers d'adeptes pour
rendre leur c'est une aubaine la roller
skate est prévue juste assez large pour
que le jeans recouvre la chaussure un
mètre de diamètre 50 cm par cheville
c'est jean pachydermique arrive tout
droit de los angeles
jean cau le fabricant prévoit un
raz-de-marée de jambes larges dans les
années à venir il fallait l'inventer le
lacet trompe l'oeil parce qu'on aurait
tort de s'encombrer de gestes inutiles
ouailles à l'élastique ça arrive
d'australie a déjà conquis dit-on le
coeur de naomi campbell côté paraissent
on peut aussi enfilé ses tennis comme
des pantoufles celles ci sont signés
boulettes et assure un système
d'aération 100% simplifier la fête de la
scène sous un ciel plutôt radieux les
parisiens sont venus en nombre
participer à cette première édition
vingt mille promenades gratuites sur le
fleuve brocante exposition animations
nautiques l'a fait déborder sur les
berges patricia charnelet yanncik elle
rendre la scène où parisien c'est
l'objectif de cette première scène
la mairie de paris veut faire de la
scène l'une des plus belle avenue du
monde
valoriser ses 35 km de berges bref
freiner l'envahissement de l'automobile
chaque jour 150 mille véhicules
circulent le long du fleuve ce week-end
les cyclistes et les piétons étaient
privilégiées les ponts sont les magali
lamballe et au plus vite
me nation se développer plus rapidement
et la restauration générale qui se doit
être des lieux et pour la promenade pour
la fête pour la culture et le sport
plusieurs initiatives ont été prises
pour cette première fête une pro quant
au pied de la tour eiffel 20000
promenades gratuites en bateau 1000
vélos prêtés des animations nautiques au
port de berthier déjà en 1941 des joutes
se dérouler sur le fleuve en 1927 par
zéro degré les nageurs disputer la coupe
de noël
la scène pourrait donc retrouver le goût
des fêtes d'antan pour la plus grande
joie des enfants vont se garer au
parking souterrain du louvre puis on a
commencé à se balader à partir de là et
alors voila voila on est très content fo
que le temps est à peu près correct et
le vainqueur pouvait pas bien oui
l'année prochaine la fête devrait
s'étoffer
en attendant les célébrations de l'an
2000 à paris où le fleuve sera le roi
johnny hallyday hier soir enflammé les
80000 spectateurs du stade de france
avide de retrouver leur idole le talent
l'énergie du rockeur la magie des effets
spéciaux et en duo pascal obispo patrick
bruel ou encore jean jacques goldman une
soirée qui éclipse tous les ratés de la
veille louis carzou hérésie ce matin
non
oui
avec le retour de cieux plus cléments
les retrouvailles entre johnny et son
public ont enfin pu avoir lieu hier soir
au stade de france et le plaisir de
cette rencontre semblait faire tout
oublier le retard d'une soirée la rareté
des billets même chez ceux que la pluie
avait privé de botter un coup de tête
rageur mais je vais les rotors à 2
johnny n'a pas de prières pas de prix
pour entendre trois heures durant
l'idole des jeunes chanter en duo avec
une centaine de musiciens ou même en
solo son seul credo je me sens
c'est bon
mais pas mis leur nom c'était parfait
super adieu un vrai dieu johnny hallyday
fait notre dieu
gravée dans la mémoire de quelques 80
mille fans la soirée d'hier n'est
sûrement déjà et que tous les autres ne
s'inquiète points lorsqu'il le noir se
fait sur une étoile comme johnny
hallyday avec un au revoir
la 55e mostra de venise avec notamment
en compétition trois films français dans
voleurs de vie qui sort sur les écrans
mercredi prochain
sandrine bonnaire et emmanuelle béart
sont les deux interprètes fort de ce
long métrage tourné à ouessant et c'est
à nouveau au bord de l'eau mais cette
fois ci est à venise que parce qu'elle
défend christophe airaud les ans
rencontrée elles ont travaillé avec les
mêmes réalisateurs mais jamais en même
temps et voilà que l'un d'entre eux leur
a offert une improbable complicité tant
il est rare qu'un scénario offrant deux
actrices de rôle d'envergure tel est le
défi de voleurs de vie emmanuelle et
sandrine joue deux soeurs alda et olga
l'une à renoncer un jour aux plaisirs de
la vie l'autre brûle la sienne d'un
homme à l'autre sans plus de conviction
deux extrêmes en apparence qui les
condamnent à une même solitude le manche
parfaite mais à l'envers
un diamant à tout ce qui y est c'est
dommage de rester enfermé comme ça
toujours toute seule j'ai pas si sale
j'ai ma fille et ma soeur du reste comme
vous le savez m'a servi pour des raisons
pour repousser suivre moi je sais que
c'est très loin d'être accomplie
avec nos soeurs mais il n'y a pas de ça
ne m'empêche pas de vivre
alors que là on a l'impression qu'elles
font
elles sont tellement unique salle et
empêche d'aller
c'est aller à l'extérieur
sur ce film eyes avec son
je crois temps
un pacte de solidarité
fait entendre
et à
très peu besoin sur
vous n'êtes pas ce qu'on arrive aussi
d'enfants
dans cet âge tout à fait particulier de
la trentaine
son
j'ai dire que
que ça passe vite déjà ça serait quand
même plus agréable pour toi si tu
habites avec quelques noms
les deux actrices se renvoient la balle
mais à la fin de la partie il y a ni
vainqueur ni vaincu
juste le constat terrifiant que celui
qui ne vit pas pleinement sa vie cela
fait voler qu'est ce que tu connais des
hommes à part les voir bien huilée dans
la chambre et attentatoire de rôle
oui mais moi je vais pas comme une
voleuse d'écouté à la porte chaque fois
car les mais là il y as au cinéma des
coupes de légende peut on associer deux
femmes douceur les deux actrices
françaises ont réussi leur pari sans se
voler la vedette
elle offre deux visages d'un même
personnage fine qui symbolise toute la
condition humaine et celle de dieppe est
envahi par les cerfs-volants bas les
aérien dimanche oiseaux de papier qui
voyage au gré du vent pour ce festival
le plus grand d'europe
trois cent mille personnes avec des yeux
d'enfants frédéric bonnet égale simard
pour ces oiseaux imaginaires la vie ne
tient qu'à un fil
ils appartiennent à ceux venus du monde
entier qui ont toujours la tête dans les
nuages
et pour ceux qui ont les pieds sur terre
voici le budget c'est la nouvelle
discipline des fous de vitesse
il est nécessaire d' à bien maîtriser la
voile et c'est important jette sur qui
n'a plus grand chose d'ailleurs à voir
avec un cerf-volant puisque c'est une
loi qui est très fort et ensuite eh bien
il ya la voile a dirigé plus le char ça
fait deux choses c'est ce qui fait tout
l'intérêt de cette discipline ce sport
un score qui ne pardonne pas la moindre
inattention de l'attention à eux ils en
note
ces chevaliers du ciel japonais
aujourd'hui à l'entraînement ont
débarqué à dieppe pour les championnats
du monde de cerfs-volants acrobatiques
pour faire comme eux c'est très facile
il suffit de s'entraîner quatre fois par
jour pendant au moins cinq ans sport à
présent avec ce marathon à travers les
vignobles du médoc une épreuve hautement
original 7500 concurrents déguisés ou
non sur 42 km david wacey philippe dumas
y au départ c'est un marathon comme les
autres 42 km à courir le plus rapidement
possible mais en observant certains
coureurs tag à la crise est là voilà les
dalton
on se demande que fait la police en
charge est arrivée je dirais même but on
cherche norman une enquête mêlant caire
l'enquète des dupond dupont n'est pas
facile car avant la ligne d'arrivée il y
à une multitude de domaines viticoles
pour brouiller les pistes et les esprits
monsieur faibli voilà pour redémarrer
voilà vous allez voir vous allez
rattraper le premier il est passé il ya
trois quarts d'heure les gendarmes sont
sur les dents mais sur ce marathon là le
dopage aux vins du médoc est conseillé
c'est pour cela qu'ils viennent du monde
entier pour sillonner les vignobles tous
les amis au long à la cabane chez nous
mais ici c'est encore pire
c'est encore mieux
ouais les kilomètres s'accumulent et le
rythme s'en ressent les verres de vin
font leur effet mais fait combien de
château aujourd'hui 7,8 à chaque mais ça
tourne à paix maintenant
dans les châteaux où on a même oublié la
ligne d'arrivée quant à lenquête des
dupond dupont
elle piétine mais je pense que mon frère
est sur une piste mais je dirais même
plus ça fait longtemps vont chercher à
arriver et on avait bien là tout est
finalement ça n'était qu'une question de
temps
le premier à trouver la ligne d'arrivée
en 2h24 les derniers en plus de 12
heures c'est la fin de cette édition je
vous en rappelle les principaux titres
l'hommage vibrant à kurzawa celui qui
fut l'un des maîtres du cinéma mondial
c'était un aujourd'hui on lui a de
nombreux chefs-d'oeuvre comme les sept
samouraïs ou kagemusha au canada les
deux boîtes noires de l'appareil de la
suisse air sont localisées pourraient
être remontées aujourd'hui les
conversations entre pilotes et tour de
contrôle ont été rendus publics
tout de suite la météo nathalie rihouet
puis votre série urgences
en deuxième partie de soirée un document
dans le secret de la police de pascal
martin et jacques cotta demain 13h
carole gaessler et rachid arhab
abatteurs vous retrouver et claude
sérillon
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2